So, what we saw in this last quiz was
really interesting. Remember that we
started out with 3^2 times 3^4, and we ended up
with 3^6 power.
What we need to notice here is how the
exponents are related to each other. 2+4,
our two original exponents, is equal to 6,
the final exponent. So, this actually
shows us a general rule for multiplying
factors that have exponents. If the two
numbers are multiplying together have the
same base, then their exponents just add
to one another, and the base stays the
same. So, let's write that in a more
general way. If we have some number, or
variable a, and it's taken to the power of
b, and that's multiplied by another number
a that's taken to the power c. Then
together, that multiplication can be
written as a^b+c.
So, like we saw in the last quiz,
3^2 times 3^4=3^2+4=3^6, just like we found out
in the end. Since exponents indicate
repeated multiplication, since each of
these factors right here is just the
number or variable a being multiplied by
itself over and over again some number of
times. When they are multiplied together,
it's just even more a's multiplied
together, or some different number of a's
multiplied together. This is just a
convenient way for us to not have to write
out all of the numbers like we did when we
were doing this last quiz.